hello everybody and welcome to this
raider special countdown to kickoff hey
it's almost time hi i'm chris matthews
here to talk raiders football
is john treach kevin martin and rob
futrell there are lots of reasons to
take notice of the raiders this season
from the veterans to the new free agents
and recently drafted players
it's no wonder raider nation is looking
to the future with
optimism now for the next 30 minutes
we're going to take a look at what makes
up this version of the raiders a veteran
quarterback
with a receiver room that is loaded with
talent there's a huge dallas connection
on this team
also a unlv connection former rebel
javen white
is trying to make an impression but we
start with the biggest impression from
camp
and that was raiders getting their first
look inside a legion stadium
with more on that unique experience we
turned to john treach john how many
players in their careers can actually
christen a new stadium
we had a chance to go inside and it is
all as advertised
it's pretty exclusive chris you're right
now rarely in life can an empty building
be breathtaking
but one step into allegiance stadium and
two billion dollars of brilliance
washes over you with proud streaks of
silver and black
it is a man-made marvel for the first
time ever the palace on the las vegas
trip
opened its doors for competition and
observation it is the first time many of
the players and all of the media members
have been inside since its completion
the attention to detail is evident but
so is the emptiness
nothing will make a season without fans
seem normal but it's certainly a
spectacular place to call home and
that's what the raiders did last week
with a spirited practice
very exciting being in that stadium
we're really appreciative of what mark
davis mark bedan and
these guys went through to put us in a
place like this
i just can't wait to share it with the
city of vegas
sports fans entertainment fans from
around the world
this place is a one-of-a-kind joint
we just got to keep pounding this virus
into the turf and open these doors so
people can enjoy it like we did today
it's a
spectacular uh out of sight place i know
it's very impressive man the uh
the yard keepers you know for the field
have done a great job it's really fast
it's comfortable uh i know a couple guys
thought it was gonna be artificial turf
but it turned out to be real grass so
we're very
very excited for this i haven't seen a
stadium that looks like this
ever like you know it's blacked out
looks like a nice
limousine or blacked out h2 hummer you
know it just looks real nice and big
and aggressive and then you get inside
and then it's just beautiful i mean from
the glass i kind of walked around before
the uh
practice today and um saw like the
little party area
the you know the drinks the walking
around to the club areas and stuff man
this
it wasn't a a piece unturned like
everything was nice and finished well so
i'm excited the autumn
wind is a raider anthem played during
warm-ups too now the players won't hear
any of the autumn wind howling because
their home field is a climate-controlled
paradise
but they'll hear everything else without
fans for now allegiant stadium is the
world's most expensive echo chamber ron
all right john yeah when you leave the
parking lot out at the practice facility
the intermountain healthcare performance
center in henderson there's a sign that
says
once a raider always a raider the quote
from al davis of course
the organization takes pride in bringing
the generations of raiders together now
we caught up with a couple of legendary
defenders
from the 80s who still live the
commitment to excellence
this is my house i know i don't play for
him now but this
is my house but once a raider always a
raider that's what i'm getting at
it's awesome man it's beautiful i like
the colors
especially you're good with the black
i'm good with the black for sure for
sure
rod martin and greg townsend were
terrors on defense
martin's three interceptions in super
bowl 15 is a record that still stands
every year keep my fingers crossed
nobody breaks that record in the
townsend is the raiders all-time sack
leader a position he relishes
but he wouldn't mind if one of the
raiders new guys
max crosby breaks his record in fact
townsend's helping him do it
well he didn't call me and said he was
chasing my record
and i said cool i think you're the
closest one to my record because you
want to get my record you're the first
one ever called me and some of you
chasing my record so that's why i know
you know a little bit about me
and what i'm about martin's position at
linebacker for the raiders
has had its problems recently and he
hopes this season
that changes i was really disappointed
the linebackers weren't doing the job
they should have been doing
last year and then the coaches and
everybody got together and got some more
players even uh
the defensive line has got sharpened up
a little
as well i love it i loved it and i love
the team
and i love the organization and i hope
that uh
gruden and his people are gonna turn it
around
you know i'm excited all right nice to
catch up with those great raiders of the
past
now on the offensive side of the ball
chris matthews takes us to the
quarterbacks
well thanks ryan yeah one of the biggest
names on this team plays the most
important position
it's going to be interesting to see how
quarterback derek carr operates with all
the talent surrounding him
he said he looks to his left and looks
to the right there's talented players
the receivers the tight ends and of
course
the offensive line is one of the best in
the nfl and his running backs are as
good as they come
in the west kevin martin joining us now
on more
with the person driving the raiders this
season hey kevin yeah chris derek carr
has received
plenty of criticism over the last few
seasons
we saw a glimpse of what he is capable
of in 2016 when he led the raiders to a
12-4 finish
but in the three seasons since the
silver black have failed to reach more
than seven wins total
the three-time pro bowler is entering
his seventh season in the league all
with the raiders
making 94 starts under center for the
silver and black since 2014.
when the 29 year old was asked if he had
given any thought to opting out the
season due to the hell's concerns
he said it was an easy decision for him
to play
when this thing came up i did not i have
a lot to prove
to myself i have a lot to prove to some
organization
i'm being completely honest i'm tired of
being disrespected so
there was no question i was going to
play this year well you got to love that
passion from your leader
that's for sure now ron is back and
tells us about how the fans can feel
closer to the players
through technology yeah kevin it's
through this crazy little thing called
a microphone all right it's nothing
special but it always sounds good the
raiders
have mic'd up a few of their players
during practice and this stuff is always
fun to watch and listen to we picked out
some highlights
we're going to start with the rookie
henry rugs iii
having fun today having a lot of fun
[Music]
come on here focus on something to get
better at today all right
take care of each other bro exactly and
hand me your job all right
ready one two three
hey
feels like it's gonna be a hot one today
gotta make it a great day gotta make it
a great day
gotta get back
yes indeed hunter renfro expected to be
a major players
in the raiders offense again this year
and chris is back with some thoughts on
how the raiders
will do on offense in 2020. well that's
the big question mark it's been said
that nobody outworks raiders coach john
gruden
up before sunrise working on all sorts
of schemes way after the sun sets
something else gruten is known for his
complicated offense
and nobody would know that better than
derek carr now a few years into the
program learning that offense and to
think about it back up quarterback
marcus mariota
has to try to grasp that offense in less
than six months
and not to mention learn it all during a
pandemic
i know if i was in that position you
need help man you need you need guys
that
will wrap you around the arm we're
family here we're teammates we
are both here as well as nate peterman
to lead our team and to help us win you
know if you ever watch us at practice
i if i'm in the thing marcus is talking
to a receiver nate's talking to a
receiver
when marcus is saying me and nate are
talking to guys coaching up fixing
things when nate's in me and marcus are
talking to guys trying to fix things
we're in this thing together man and so
we've all three of us have just kind of
you know in a group text just try and
help each other out and always just
trying to
you know help help that process it's
going to be hard for him you know
um you know especially with no preseason
games where he'd actually get some live
reps
so but besides that knock on wood
you know hopefully i stay healthy and he
won't have to worry about that
alright still ahead on the show there is
a coach on the raider staff that is
considered
one of the most respected in the
business we'll introduce you to veteran
coach rod marinelli
what's he saying about his new job here
in las vegas plus there's a unlv rover
from atlanta spot
on the raiders roster that more coming
up next
it's official the las vegas raiders kick
off their season september 13th against
the carolina panthers
you can watch the game right here on 8
news now home of the most raiders games
in the valley
a proud broadcast partner of the las
vegas raiders
hello i'm mike lindell inventor of my
pillow just like you i had problems
sleeping
i tried every pillow out there and
nothing worked 15 years ago i invented
my pillow
it took me two years to develop because
i wanted to have
everything you would ever want in a
pillow i made sure that you could adjust
my patented fill so you could have the
exact support you need as an individual
regardless of your sleep position
i also wanted a pillow that would last
so i made my pillow machine washable and
dryable
i backed my pillow with a 10-year
warranty on a 60-day money-back
guarantee
not only that i do all my own
manufacturing in my home state of
minnesota
i really like the fact that it was made
in the usa i think that usa products are
a better quality product
i've tried a lot of other pillows and
nothing's worked like my pillow i'm
interrupting this commercial right now
to give you deep discounts
not just on my pillows but also my
mattress topper sheets and
so much more for example you can get
body pills regular 89.99
now only 29.99 or my pillow dog beds for
as low as 19.99 with your promo code
i used to think that sheets were just
sheets i got the giza dream
sheets they are the most comfortable
sheets i've ever had
the go anywhere pillow is so easy to
just roll up
and take anywhere i want to go go
anywhere pillow is really comfortable so
that's what i really like it's nice and
supportive and it's nice and small
the my pillow topper for the first time
has enabled me to have a cool
night's sleep i'll be able to go to bed
and just get rest
that's three inches of wonderful that's
in the my pillow mattress topper it's
just like a
firm cloud my pillow helps me get a good
night's sleep
so i can do my job in the morning go to
mypillow.com to get deep discounts
not just on my pillows but so much more
for example you get body pills regular
89.99
now only 29.99 or my pillow dog beds for
as low as 19.99 with your promo code
for the best night's sleep in the whole
wide world visit mypillow.com
because car wrecks don't take the
weekends off neither do we and don't
wait until monday to get the help you
need
now learner role we're available to take
your call 24 7. and get you the help you
need
right now is the way to go
call 877 500.
welcome back to the show something
unique about this team it's cowboy
connection
some of the guys on this team traded
their spurs in dallas for eye patches in
vegas there are a number of former
cowboys who are donning the silver and
black
one of those could be a key to the
defensive side of the raiders this
season malik collins
is going to be counted on for some big
things this year he's a three
technique defensive lineman basically
means he'll line up in the middle trying
to get to the backfield as soon as
possible
whether to pressure the quarterback or
find the flow to the ball carrier he's
good at all of it
well you just bet on yourself i mean i
always been a person that
i got full of confidence in me um
i know what i'm capable of and the
offers that came to the table weren't
worthy of my abilities i don't believe
so i think that
a one year was the best option to go
earn more
excited to see this player one of the
reasons collins is in vegas is because
of veteran defensive guru rod marinelli
he's been around a long long time kevin
martin has more on that cowboy
connection
yeah chris you talk about that cowboy
connection well the former dallas
defensive coordinator rod marinelli
became available after the coaching
change in the lone star state and john
gruden
couldn't pass up the opportunity to
bring marinelli on his staff
as the d-line coach
and speaking of connections here is also
familiarity between gruden and marinelli
they worked together in tampa during
gruden's time there as head coach
winning super bowl 37 together
now some 15 years since they last
coached together they are reunited
in vegas he's a great coach he's
all business he's tough as hell uh he
doesn't
give in to tough times he's uh
old school and uh he's also
uh on the cutting edge every year in
terms of how to rush the pastor and play
defensive line
oh i no doubt my my i work for coach in
tampa bay
i want a super bowl with him i
understand what he's about i understand
his intensity
his passion for the game and that was an
immediate draw to come back with him but
i think just getting back with coach
gruden i know what he's going to do i
know he's going to go get players
and i just like the system he runs and
i like the approach so we've talked
about malik collins and ron marinelli
and this cowboy connection stems even
further
jason winton who spent 16 seasons in
dallas cementing his place among the
all-time best tight ends to ever play
is now a raider and is looking forward
to embracing his new role as a veteran
leader here in vegas
i think that's a challenge for the
players to understand kind of you know
what's been provided here and
opportunity and
and don't take it for granted you know
it's not like this everywhere
eleven time pro bowler jason whitten
knows that what the raiders have going
on here in vegas is special
and an opportunity he couldn't pass up i
mean it's just it's been first class
and that's been a good experience and
you know i'm coming from as you said a
kind of the um maybe the leader of first
class and how you do it in the dallas
cowboys so i
had great experience there so there's a
buzz with that
during his tenure in dallas winton
became one of the most dominant tight
ends in the league
but now at 38 his role as a raider will
look much different i think when you get
to this age
it's all about the fit and the role and
made a lot of sense for me you know it's
a
really talented roster it's young and
want to come in and be a veteran
presence for him
and at this point in his career i think
it's safe to say that whitton has pretty
much seen it all
well that was until he laid eyes on john
gruden's infamous playbook
you know coach gruden's is a new age
condensed
playbook so i've mastered the first
thousand pages only got about 9 000 more
to go but
it is different it's a different
experience for me putting on that
uniform the other day for the first time
but
i just try to make the most of those and
and really a lot of joy and passion
to have this opportunity and i'll tell
you what you heard whitney talk about
the talent on this roster there sure is
a lot of that at the tight end position
the savvy vet will no doubt fit in
nicely with daryn waller foster murrow
and derek carrier chris all right still
ahead on this countdown to kickoff
raiders have over 30 free agents looking
to land a spot in the nfl
one of those is a former unlv rebel
you'll hear what the rebels are saying
about him plus
one of the most interesting rooms is
that receiver room who's in who's out
tough decision to be made more
next now more than ever
you need someone working for you that's
why we're adding more local news with
eight news now
live at four it's what's new now and
next
news that gets to the point starting
september 14th
storm tracker 8 is there when storms
blow through the valley
that's why you trust storm tracker 8 to
give you
the most accurate forecast storm tracker
8 the valley's most accurate forecast
5 years in a row only on 8 news now free
for free free
free free thursday through monday at
tobin kia
your vehicle registration is free plus
new key is below invoice or get zero
percent financing
tobagia free registration when you get
here are you behind on your mortgage
is the bank threatening to take your
home are you considering trying to get a
loan modification on your own
did you know that less than five percent
of people who tried on their own
actually got a modification
at the mortgage modification helpline we
know the rules and regulations banks
don't want you to know about
and we've helped thousands of people
stay in their homes
so call the mortgage modification
helpline today
please call 800-630-8751
we know y'all have got a lot of catching
up to do meet church's new go box
the official box of gathering around
brought to you by the connoisseurs of
coming together since 1952
we're talking your choice of chicken
your choice of size and scratch made
honey butter biscuits
so for whoever you choose to call family
and however you choose to get together
today
this is your new go to church's gold box
feed six or more starting at 20 bucks
churches
bringing that down home flavor
contact tracing gives us the information
needed to draw a road map of how
coronavirus
is traveling throughout nevada but we
can't draw that map without
help if you get a phone call from a
contact tracer they will identify
themselves and ask you for specific
information
none of that information will be given
to anyone else in any way
and contact tracing absolutely does not
ask you for certain information
with your help we can get all the
information needed to get a handle on
covid19
and stop the spread free for free free
free
free thursday through monday at tobin
kia your vehicle registration
is free plus new key is below invoice or
get zero percent financing tobagia
free registration when you get here
you know welcome back of the 30 or so
free agents the raiders have on the
roster
one of those is a former unlb rebel
javen white
he's one of the best defensive players
in the mountain west john treach back
with more on white john
it's a long shot for any of these free
agents but especially in a year like
this
no rookie camps no mini camps no
organized team activities
not to mention preseason games making an
nfl roster as an
undrafted free agent is a success story
and a surprise but
don't you dare call javen white
cinderella the linebacker out of unlv
made plays for four years in las vegas
and
now is tackling the biggest challenge of
his life but this isn't rudy part two
javen white belongs but the white story
gets better the six foot two 220 pound
ball seeking missile was born and raised
in oakland
he came to unlv with very few other
opportunities and earned college
football's respect
after being skipped over for the combine
and having his pro day canceled due to
kovid
white went undrafted but stayed overly
prepared
he didn't want to be interviewed until
after he made the team but
we talked to him the day he was signed
by the raiders
you know the film does a lot they've
already pulled up the tape they've
already did their homework and army
they know exactly what type of player
they're getting in as soon as i step in
that meeting room i i i plan on
just displaying everything that they
already know as far as
young guys who stuck out um i saw
javin white come downhill a few times
like an animal and put his head in some
insula so i can't cuss so yeah he put
his head in there but
he uh yeah he he did some good things
he's been called javin and javin but
mostly impressive don't be surprised
raider nation if you're hearing a lot of
javen white's name chris well the
linebacking group looks pretty solid
also and so does that receiver room
there might not be a more competitive
room than the receiver room there are 10
receivers listed on the positional
roster
tyrell williams has said he's going to
try to play through a torn
labrum he's a vet raiders have a few
rookies in that room like henry ruggs
and brian edwards
they'll make the roster but what about
pickups like
zay jones or keelandos it's tough and
learning this system that's also a
challenge as second year
receiver hunter renfro found out at
clemson it was all like one words like
it was spread right and we just say one
word and everybody knew what to do
and i was it was funny i was talking to
nelson yesterday
on uh during our walk through and he was
saying how much fun this offense is
because you don't just teach one play
like maybe in philadelphia where he was
saying that
one receiver just knows what he does on
that play everybody knows what
everybody's doing on this play you teach
concepts here
and so you could have a play called
and then you could rotate it and
everybody's in a different spot
and still the same play called and so
it's just a lot of fun all right sounds
like fun still to come raiders owner
mark davis
had to be on cloud nine when he saw the
team take the stadium for the very first
time
my father always said that the greatness
of the raiders
is in its future well today that future
truly starts welcome more with mark
davis coming up here on
countdown to kickoff
now more than ever you need someone
working for you that's why we're adding
more local news with eight news now
live at four it's what's new now and
next
news that gets to the point starting
september 14th
get huge labor day savings on everything
now through monday at tobin fiat alfa
romeo
save a flat five grand off new fiat new
alfa romeos only 349 a month and used
cars from 59.95
tobin fiat alpha romeo on jones and
sahara looking for a gorgeous smile
smiles today dental continues to offer
the lowest prices in town on braces for
all ages
right now braces start at just 39 a
month with approved credit free
consultation is available for new braces
patients smiles today dental stuck on
eggs
bird on batter you can't escape the
nightmare of your sticky pans
introducing the granite stone pan the
all-new
durable non-stick pan no butter or oil
needed
watch we melted down these sticky
candies in granite stone
and it just doesn't stick we cooked a
half a dozen eggs bacon cheese and
tomato breakfast with no butter or oil
and it just doesn't stick fire flom bay
or perfectly sear fillet
just like the pros plus it's pfoa free
and 100
dishwasher safe call or go online to get
your granite stone pan for just
19.99 granite stone is so durable it
comes with a 10 year warranty and with
every order you're going to get a
granite stone
single serve eggplant absolutely free
we'll even ship your entire order
free you get it all an incredible value
to order call
1-800-898-5687 eight nine eight five six
eight seven that's one eight
eight seven or order online
at by granite stone.com
[Music]
get huge labor day savings on everything
now through monday at tobin fiat alfa
romeo save a flat five grand
off new fiat new alpha romeo's only 349
a month
and used cars from 59.95 tobin fiat
alpha romeo on jones and sahara
all right raiders took the field to the
legion stadium for the first time on
august 21st it was a big deal
it was the first time for many of the
players and coaches they'd been inside
this thing
as the players gathered on the natural
turf raiders owner mark davis delivered
a quick
heartfelt speech from the concourse
level
welcome to the death star this is our
field of dreams
this is our house the stadium's
personality
will be defined by you so take
pride every time you step on this field
wearing those famed black jerseys and
silver helmets
you are the raiders so i'll leave you
with three words
just win baby welcome home
all right welcome home that was an
impressive outing witnessing for the
very first time that two
billion dollar facility we bring in john
kevin and ron for some more thoughts
on the raiders as they get set to embark
on a new era of raiders football i'm
most impressed with derek carr his
commitment
he gathered his players on his own to
work this past summer
of course in the parks here in las vegas
he said he'd be surprised if the team
worked any harder
in the off season under the strained
circumstances john your quick
impressions
well everyone's a super bowl contender
in august but is this team any good
they haven't won a playoff game in 18
years can they break that and can they
do it
in las vegas chris hey kevin how about
you yeah chris i really like the roster
so far compiled i think it's a great mix
between
young talent and old savvy vets i'm
really excited to see if they can
actually put it together on the field
this season
chris lots of veterans lots of free
agents some draft picks ron how about
you well i like the stadium being here
in the city okay we've needed a stadium
like this to be a big time city
and we've got it now thanks to the
raiders the nfl the taxpayers of the
state of nevada all coming together
to make this happen it's great to see
some of the great special events there
chris i'm hoping for a zeppelin reunion
got to get on the phone with jimmy page
later today and see if we can get
zeppelin to come
no great events we'll be coming to this
stadium in our city now and that's great
all right thank you very much that is
our show raiders open the season on the
road at carolina
and their home opener is september 21st
it's a monday night against the saints
thanks for watching for john kevin and
ron i'm chris matthews
enjoy the raiders season and have a
great day everybody
you